oh
i'm not getting any younger which is why
exercise has become important to me and
i got pretty into cycling but i'm also
not getting any wiser i continue to be
an idiot
so i decided to ride my bicycle all the
way from los
angeles to san diego and i took it so
seriously i got to training i wanted to
get in good shape
and test out different camera angles on
my bicycle
all right let's ride so i did this whole
hollywood tour
right down hollywood boulevard through
the sunset
strip looping through beverly hills
i was having a blast what's that
night at the roxbury but since i knew
there was a camera on the bike recording
me
i was trying to go as fast as i could
and as i took this one turn
i had the worst bike crash of my life
[Music]
i couldn't even get up and some people
asked if i was okay i said yeah
but that was a lie yeah okay thank you
and it took me a while to even pick my
bike up
and then i got back to the house and
showed looks all my injuries
it's this whole side of my body just got
worse how did your hair get cut baby
you've got that thing on there let me
see your elbow
the cuts and scrapes were minor it was
my hip that really took a blow
where like if i'm honest it's still not
right today
like my pelvis like that whole like
joint
and like i said i'm an idiot so i
stopped training completely
but kept planning my trip and my plans
were insane
i'm not gonna let myself sleep in a
hotel i have to sleep in a little
sleeping bag and tent that i've got
strapped to my bike i'm not allowed to
get any food i only eat what's
in the bag on my bike zero sugar
hydration man element dude
and i'm gonna go over a hundred [__]
miles like it's insane
but i had to do it because these nice
people gave me like a ten thousand
dollar bike
yeah mosaic and shimano
and the cub house bike shop who put it
together so there was no question that i
was gonna go through with this
but i had not even sat on a bicycle for
months
until the day before my mission when i
got professionally fitted to my bike
by dialed in innovative bike fitting and
i know everything about this plant is
nuts
but i don't care because i'm gnarly what
do they do
they clip onto my [__] pedals that's
why i ate [__] so bad
so i started out at lake hollywood with
the killer drone
shot i'm not in particularly good shape
but is that going to stop me from trying
to ride from hollywood all the way to
carlsbad california
straight through compton hell no
it's on yeah
later dog have fun
and when i set off i was flying down the
hollywood hills
the plan was for scott randolph to catch
up to me and pace me with the car
he can't even catch up to me i'd like to
say that he couldn't catch me because i
was going so fast
but really it's just la traffic is
terrible but not for me man i went
right through it at this point the
longest i had ever ridden in one day was
30 miles
and i was gonna [__] blow that out of
the water
[Music]
40 [__] miles [__] and i
stopped a couple times
but barely just long enough to mount
down a can of tuna
and get back on the road and i powered
through until
sunset [__] 50 miles
and if you think i stopped riding
because it got dark you're very wrong
i kept riding through the night until i
doubled my record
going over 60 miles and then i thought
about looking for a good place to sleep
and it occurred to me there is no good
place to sleep
so i picked some bushes by a bridge all
right
and at that point i was so spent i
called up lux and she asked if i had my
bike locked up
and i just got grumpy with her are you
so that you can lock up your bike baby
i'm sorry i'm so sore and [__] tired
there's nothing left of me
this is where i'm at this is how it's
going down so i take my sleep system off
the handlebars and set it up in the
bushes
and i think because it's designed to be
so light
somehow the condensation just goes
straight through it
so it's sopping wet immediately and i
called my girl back to apologize
and we had a pretty good laugh when she
asked how my trip was
[Applause]
then i finished getting ready for bed
and had the worst night's sleep ever
i didn't do a whole lot of sleeping man
and then when i emerged from my tent at
like six in the morning
i was so cold and i put on my arm
warmers and just got ready to ride but
my
body felt like [__] so sore
and my maps is telling me that i have to
climb 2500 feet of elevation
and i'm just like come on
but i promised myself no way i'm getting
off the bike and walking it up the hill
of course at one point my legs just gave
out
and i fell over with my feet clipped to
the pedals
so i ate another can of tuna and then
kept going
and the whole route i had been on was
pretty inland
so when i finally reached the beach
there was like a real feeling of
satisfaction
check me out dude i made it somewhere
that is the ocean but i knew i wasn't
gonna make it up any more hills
and scott randolph was coming down to
get me with the drone
but once he got it i got in his car and
said
drive me home because i was done dude
your legs gave out
how long ago a couple hours
i only made it to san clemente not
carlsbad i only went 86.9 miles
not a hundred and thirteen but
[__] i'd rather be the guy who taps out
early and admits it
then hops in a van secretly to be driven
to the destination to celebrate no
no i have integrity okay i bitched out
after
86.9 miles and i feel good about it
because i got integrity
and you know what you can have integrity
too
if you go to stevo.com and buy yourself
some [__] and merch
or check out my killer crazy comedy
special gnarly
are we ready yeah
[Music]
thank you for watching the tale of my
epic mission